madame la Présidente bonjour et encore
toutes nos excuses pour ce retard la
précédente audition ayant duré un peu
plus que prévu donc nous sommes heureux
de vous recevoir aujourd'hui en votre
qualité de présidente duo conseil pour
le climat vous exercez depuis 2018 la
présidence du Haut Conseil pour le
climat qui est je le rappelle un
organisme indépendant chargé des maîtres
des avis et des recommandations sur la
mise en oeuvre des politiques publiques
pour réduire les émissions de gaz à
effet serre de la France vous êtes
également climatologue et professeur en
sciences du changement climatique à
l'université d'Istan vous avez été
précédemment auteur du Groupe
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat GIEC et co-présidente du Global
carbone project votre audition doit nous
permettre de mieux comprendre la
position du Haut conseil sur le climat
sur l'efficacité des politiques
publiques qu'en matière de rénovation
énergétique alors que vous avez publié
en novembre 2020 un rapport sur le sujet
intitulé rénover mieux le son d'Europe
dans ce rapport qui fait suite à une
saisine du gouvernement vous insistez
sur le retard pris par la France qui
apparaît comme ayant les logements les
moins performants par rapport à la Suède
les Pays-Bas le Royaume-Uni et
l'Allemagne des quatre pays étudiés dans
le cadre de votre étude vous identifiez
des blocages qui expliquent ce retard
observé alors que les politiques mises
en oeuvre sont selon vous inadaptés aux
besoins de rénovation profonde autant
long nécessaire à la rénovation et
également à la structuration de la
filière et que les capacités de
financement des ménages apparaissent
trop faibles
plus de deux ans après la publication du
rapport se retard est-il selon vous
toujours aussi conséquent dans quelle
mesure la loi climat est résilience de
2021 a-t-elle répondu à vos
préconisations parmi celles qui n'ont
pas été encore mis en œuvre lesquelles
vous paraissent les plus importantes la
focalisation des aides sur les
rénovations les plus performantes la
suppression du taux de TVA à 5,5 pour
transformer les crédits alloués sur les
rénovations globales l'augmentation des
contrôles ou porter à 120.000 euros le
montant de l'éco PTZ enfin vous avez
insisté tout au long de votre rapport
sur la nécessité d'une plus grande
planification et d'une visibilité en
matière de rénovation énergétique pour
assurer cette stabilité
la ministre Barbara Pompidou que nous
avons auditionné à évoquer l'adoption
d'une loi de programmation de la
rénovation énergétique qui permettrait
une planification plurie annuelle
l'adoption d'une telle loi vous
semble-t-elle pertinente ou une annexe à
la prochaine programmation plus réelle
de l'énergie la PPE serait-elle
suffisante avant de vous laisser la
parole pour répondre à ses premières
questions et pour un propos introductif
d'une vingtaine de minutes il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles à 434-13
434-14
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc madame la Présidente
a prêté serment de dire toute la vérité
rien que la vérité a levé la main droite
et à dire je le jure
je vous en remercie je vous laisse la
parole maintenant et ensuite bien sûr
notre rapporteur vous posera un certain
nombre de questions ainsi que l'ensemble
de nos collègues présents dans cette
salle
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
merci beaucoup de dans ton le Haut
Conseil pour le climat aujourd'hui comme
vous venez de le dire le Haut Conseil
pour le climat est un organisme
indépendant qui est inscrit dans la loi
énergie climat de 2019 il est chargé
d'évaluer la stratégie du gouvernement
en matière de climat et sa cohérence
avec l'accord de Paris il met en relief
les actions de la France par rapport à
celle des autres pays et il émet des
avis et des recommandations indépendants
et objectifs sur le l'action de la
France
dans le cadre de ces missions le HTC
doit rendre chaque année un rapport sur
le respect de la trajectoire de baisse
des émissions au regard des budgets
carbone de la France et c'est dans le
cadre de ce rapport où on fait un suivi
bien sûr des émissions de en provenance
des bâtiments ce rapport doit aussi
regarder l'impact socio-économique des
actions et le gouvernement doit répondre
à ce rapport dans les six mois et c'est
ce cycle de rapport réponse qui est qui
se veut un cycle vertueux qui doit
servir à rehausser le niveau des actions
c'est dans le cadre de cette évaluation
annuelle que nous suivons les évolutions
mais on nous avons aussi publié après
une saisie de gouvernement en rapport de
parents gonage sur la rénovation
énergétique du bâtiment où nous avons
comparé les actions de la France avec
celle de la Suède de l'Allemagne des
Pays-Bas et du Royaume-Uni
déjà premièrement constat le dernier
constat sur les émissions dans le
secteur du bâtiment donc le secteur du
bâtiment et
responsable de 18% des émissions en
France les émissions directes provenant
des bâtiments donc c'est un des grands
secteurs émetteurs après les transports
mais en même temps au même niveau à peu
près que l'agriculture et l'industrie le
avec le chauffage qui est le poste qui
génère le plus d'émissions donc les
chaudières fuel et au gaz les demandes
en énergie pour se chauffer sans doute
en plus importantes que les bâtiments
sont mal isolés et donc qu'on peut avoir
potentiellement des pertes d'énergie qui
pourraient être évitées
c'est de plus quand on tient compte bien
sûr des émissions qui sont associées à
l'électricité et au réseau de chaleur la
part des bâtiments s'élèvent à environ
28% donc soit un peu plus d'un quart des
émissions ce secteur peut et donc doit
arriver à pratiquement zéro émission
pour atteindre la neutralité carbone au
niveau de la France en 2050 et répondre
justement aux changements climatique
tant qu'on n'a pas atteint la neutralité
carbone au niveau global le
réchauffement de la planète va continuer
donc c'est vraiment un objectif très
important pour la France pour au niveau
mondial mais aussi pour le secteur du
bâtiment
et le secteur du bâtiment peut arriver à
cette neutralité carbone ou en tout cas
pratiquement avec une rénovation
thermique globale de l'ensemble du parc
ou autant que possible une efficacité
des augmentations de l'efficacité
énergétique et un chauffage bacarbone
soit pompe de chaleur électrique ou
réseau de chaleur bas carbone
on pourrait pas dire on pourrait
simplement substituer le chauffage au
gaz et fuel par un chauffage baccarmon
ce n'est pas possible car la demande
supplémentaire du coup sur le réseau
électrique se serait trop forte vu
l'expansion de la demande anticipée des
autres secteurs en particulier le
transport et l'industrie et donc
améliorer la performance énergétique des
logements c'est essentiel et ça comporte
aussi plusieurs cours bénéfices dont la
réduction de la facture énergétique
l'amélioration du confort thermique et
la réduction des externalités liées à
l'énergie la rénovation énergétique est
aussi un gésier d'emploi très important
et c'est donc pour ça pour justement
arriver à la neutralité carbone le plus
vite possible dans le secteur du
bâtiment ou en tout cas très près que il
nous faut en France une planification à
long terme où on va rehausser les
efforts les actions qui sont mises en
place à l'heure actuelle et on va les
maintenir sur le long terme jusqu'à
cette atteinte de la neutralité carbone
les tendances actuelles observées ne
sont pas suffisantes pour atteindre les
objectifs de réduction qui sont inscrits
dans la stratégie nationale bas carbone
déjà avant de vous donner quelques
chiffres je veux dire que ce secteur du
bâtiment c'est un des trois secteurs et
metteurs qui voient leur tendance
diminuer donc il y a des efforts qui
sont déjà mis en place et qui payent
déjà alors actuel donc il voit leur
tendance diminuer de manière
structurelle depuis plus d'une décennie
avec le secteur de l'énergie et de
l'industrie et on dit de manière
structurelle parce que on a déjà la
Revan 20 qui donne les critères sur le
neuf on a eu des financements nouveaux
en particulier au sein du plan de
relance de la covid 19 qui a augmenté le
niveau des financements et on a pour
donner un autre exemple cette
observatoire de la rénovation
énergétique qui amène des informations
qui permet de guider en plus des
instruments qui sont déjà en place donc
c'est vraiment une baisse structurelle
le problème qu'on a c'est que cette
baisse elle est pas au bon niveau et
c'est ce qu'on voit
au sein de plusieurs actions en France
et aussi ailleurs c'est que on est sur
une tendance à la baisse mais cette
tendance à la baisse elle est trop
faible
les émissions pour vous donner quelques
chiffres donc on parle d'un secteur de
75 millions de tonnes de CO2 donc ces
émissions ont diminué de 1,9 millions de
tonnes sur le par année sur la période
du 1er budget carbone donc 2015-2018
une diminution qui a été ralenti sur les
deux dernières années avec avec les
mesures du covid 19 et le rosement du
télétravail en particulier mais cette
baisse annuelle elle devrait dépasser
les entre les trois et quatre donc voir
doubler cette baisse en émission visée
par la trajectoire de la stratégie
nationale bancaire monde sur la période
2022 2030 et en plus avec l'augmentation
de l'objectif 2030 au niveau européen on
doit effectivement surpasser ses
objectifs qui sont actuellement dans la
loi et on y est pas
le rythme de baisse il est trop faible
le premier budget carbone a été dépassé
et du coup on a ce besoin d'augmentation
du rythme de baisse des émissions
comme la confirmer le bilan de
l'Observatoire de la rénovation
énergétique que vous avez entendu dans
cette commission le nombre d'opérations
de rénovations à lui fortement augmenté
depuis 2016 avec les données disponibles
mais du coup les dispositifs de
subventions et de financement actuel
encourage en fait peu les rénovations
globales profondes qui permettent de
faire des gains en fait les gains sont
faites au niveau du chauffage bas
carbone de la rénovation de l'enveloppe
avant les rénovations par gestes
et ce malgré les évolutions des
dispositifs qui sont plus récents par
exemple selon les données de Lana de
l'agence de nationale de l'habitation
les rénovations globales ne
représenterait que de 0,1% des travaux
financés par le dispositif ma prime
rénov et de la même façon le ciblage des
autres aides encouragent davantage les
rénovations partielles avec des gains
énergétiques qui sont limitées
contrairement à l'objectif de vraiment
s'encrer sur une trajectoire de
massification de la rénovation
énergétique complète performante et là
on parle de beaucoup d'instruments qui
justement encouragent ces gestes vous
avez parlé de la TVA à tout réduit de
5,5% de l'éco-prés à taux accessible
sans condition et les dispositions du
CEA certaines dispositions ponctuelles
les travaux du coup qui sont financés
pour l'essentiel
finance des travaux immédiats qui ne
permettent pas d'atteindre cette
performance globale satisfaisante
la réglementation environnementale du
bâtiment neuf Lavin elle structure les
stratégies des acteurs de la
construction donc c'est une avancée
vraiment positive mais il faut déjà
qu'elle s'adapte à la révision de la
directive européenne sur la performance
énergétique du bâtiment notamment la
révision de la directive qui imposera
une exigence de construction neuf à
émission nulle d'ici à 2030 voir avant
le Haut Conseil pour le climat a fait
plusieurs recommandations pour améliorer
la situation et ces recommandations vise
en gros à essayer de vraiment développer
cette trajectoire de massification et la
première vous allez comme vous vous en
doutez c'est de réorienter la rénovation
des bâtiments vers des parcours de
rénovation globale performantes donc de
pousser tous les instruments encourager
avec tous les instruments dont on
dispose ces rénovations globales
performante donc de mettre en cohérence
et unifier les dispositifs d'aide pour
faciliter et à croître l'ambition avec
une trajectoire claire avec des
objectifs intermédiaires non seulement
sur le nombre de rénovations mais sur la
qualité attendue de ces rénovations de
réorienter les dispositifs vers ceux qui
maximisent les économies d'énergie et de
planifier les parcours de rénovation
dans la durée par exemple avec l'aide de
maître d'ouvrage et des feuilles de
suivi des feuilles de route pour les
bâtiments
deuxièmement de renforcer
l'accompagnement des ménages en
situation de précarité énergétique donc
d'organiser le subventionnement des
rénovations globales profondes soit en
visant reste à charge nulle pour les
ménages les plus précaires ou avec des
dispositifs d'accompagnement par exemple
avec l'aide de près ou de parcours de
rénovation pour les autres ménages
le conditionnement des aides publiques à
l'exigence de résultats très important
je vous ai parlé de du parangonage c'est
un c'est un des éléments de l'approche
allemande qui fonctionne bien donc
réalisé par exemple une évaluation tous
les ans de l'efficacité des dispositifs
d'aide avec une estimation des
réductions attendues et conditionner les
dispositifs d'aide à l'exigence de
résultats donc allez effectivement et
évaluée de manière ponctuelle
pour être pratique mais aller évaluer
les les rénovations qui sont faites il
s'agit là vraiment de passer de
remboursement de factures ce qui se fait
en grande partie en ce moment au
financement de la performance et à la
maîtrise de l'ouvrage donc pour faire en
sorte que l'argent public soit égal à
des rénovations qui sont vraiment
performantes
autre point il faut justement pour
masquer cette rénovation et le maintenir
sur la durée la maintenir sur la durée
il faut renforcer la formation des
professionnels de la filière donc là il
s'agit de faire un travail pour
renforcer la structuration de la filière
avec la mise en place de formation la
montée en compétences des professionnels
du bâtiment mais il s'agit aussi de
développer une programmation plus réelle
des financements publics et là ça va
au-delà du secteur du bâtiment mais ça
touche beaucoup le secteur du bâtiment
qui est au centre des financements
publics donc une programmation plus
réelle des financements publics
s'intègrent dans le cadre budgétaire de
l'État et en chiffrant les coûts des
orientations de la stratégie nationale
bas carbone dont le parcours du bâtiment
et
autre élément mettre en oeuvre et
consolider la RM20 donc elle devra
évoluer comme je l'ai dit vers ces
émissions nues nulles et il faut aussi
déjà dès maintenant anticiper les
dispositifs de l'adaptation au
changement climatique qui sont inscrits
dans la RER 20 qui vont devoir justement
se mettre en œuvre
dernier point à croître fortement le
potentiel des réseaux de chaleur c'est
ce qui fait en sorte que en particulier
en Suède on a avancé de manière très
profonde au niveau de la rénovation
énergétique du bâtiment c'est en partie
à cause du développement des réseaux de
chaleur et c'est aussi ce qui se fait de
manière très efficace au Pays-Bas où ils
ont des feuilles de route régionales
pour encourager justement les réseaux de
chaleur
donc je vais m'arrêter ici pour
l'instant et je vais continuer au niveau
des questions si vous le voulez bien
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente je
laisse la parole à notre rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente merci madame
la Présidente du Haut Conseil pour le
pour le climat pour votre votre exposé
j'avais plusieurs plusieurs questions
peut-être déjà c'est vrai que vous avez
abordé sur sur les questions relatives
aux exemples étrangers que ce soit la
Suède la Grande-Bretagne les Pays-Bas
peut-être revenir sur le vous avez parlé
de l'exemple de l'Allemagne ou pour
bénéficier d'aide publique il était
nécessaire de recourir à un expert en
énergie certifiée je trouve que ça peut
être intéressant en tout cas ça fait
partie des questions qu'on se pose
notamment pour aller sur de la
rénovation globale et avoir la
visibilité en tout cas avant de avant
d'engager des travaux quand on a
auditionné Emmanuel wargon elle nous
disait que c'était difficilement
transposable en France et qu'en tout cas
on arrivait un blocage du système
je voulais voir un petit peu votre votre
avis sur cette sur cette question
sur les Pays-Bas il y avait la question
aussi sur la dimension locale qui est
aussi quelque chose qui nous intéresse
sur comment on peut mettre la politique
de rénovation thermique en lien avec
avec les collectivités les élus et au
plus près des territoires donc de la
même manière peut-être sur les à la fois
l'exemple des Pays-Bas et puis ce que
vous voyez sur ce qui se passe sur ce
qui se passe en France sur la question
de la Suède il y avait le la question du
rapprochement en tout cas et du lien
avec les ministères sociaux
c'est vrai qu'on a parlé tout à l'heure
avec le ministre de Normandie sur le
lien entre les différents ministères
mystères de l'écologie ministère du
logement mais c'est vrai que la question
la question sociale est aussi
particulièrement
particulièrement importante
ensuite sur le sur la suite du rapport
vous avez parlé de la création la de
l'Observatoire de la rénovation
énergétique donc ça fait deux ans qu'il
est qu'il est créé on les a évidemment
auditionnés mais je voulais savoir un
petit peu ce que vous en pensiez
justement maintenant qu'il est en
fonctionnement sachant que c'était
quelque chose sur lequel vous aviez vous
aviez souhaité je pense que c'est un
vrai besoin d'avoir ce cette analyse va
avoir peut-être votre votre retour
vous vous préconisez aussi toujours dans
la même orientation d'aller plutôt sur
la rénovation globale de supprimer d'ici
trois ans des aides au gestes
individuels notamment dans ma prime
rénove c'est vrai que les différents
ministres qu'on a pu additionner enfin
on a eu des retours très très différents
mais je viens de Normandie tout à
l'heure nous a encore dit que lui il
pensait que de conserver en tout cas les
gestes uniques étaient importants parce
que c'était le présenter comme ça
c'était un premier pas en tout cas qui
permettait d'aller vers ensuite
peut-être une rénovation plus importante
derrière tout ça c'est peut-être donc
vraiment c'est justement cet
accompagnement et cette vision globale
de la rénovation et puis ensuite qui
peut se faire pas à pas
et puis peut-être une un point aussi sur
le sur le nouveau DPE et donc qui vient
d'être mis en œuvre vous avez tout
critiqué son son manque de fibres
et donc voilà maintenant que ça fait à
peu près 7 8 mois 9 mois qu'il est en
place quel est votre votre vue votre
constat par rapport à ce à ce nouveau
nouveau DPE et puis peut-être pour
terminer sur les propositions qu'il y
avait été initié par
les formuler par la Convention citoyenne
c'est vrai qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de propositions qui n'ont pas été
forcément toute retenue certaines l'ont
été peut-être avoir voilà si il y avait
des propositions qui pour vous
paraissaient paraissait essentiel en
tout cas qui aurait pu être ou qui
aurait dû être dû être retenu et puis
peut-être un petit mot et après je
m'arrête sur les déclarations en tout
cas le sur des stères Duflot dans sa
dernière leçon là au Collège de France
ou c'est vrai qu'il avait été plutôt des
des doutes notamment en raison de son
coût selon elle des effets limités
justement de la rénovation thermique
telle qu'elle était appliquée et que
c'était peut-être plus en agissant sur
là pour le coup sur les gestes face au
fonctionnement des des habitants et
notamment plutôt avec des compteurs
d'énergie etc qu'on pouvait agir
beaucoup plus que réellement en mettant
de l'argent sur la rénovation thermique
alors on a prévu effectivement de
démissionner Duflot mais savoir un petit
peu votre votre avis aussi sur ces sur
ces déclarations merci
merci beaucoup pour ce balayage donc
pour commencer avec l'exemple de la de
l'Allemagne donc
l'Allemagne ont beaucoup utilisé ce
qu'ils appellent une ingénierie
financière pour encourager les aides aux
rénovations profondes donc
plus on fait de rénovation plus la
rénovation tant vers le niveau profond
plus les aides sont importantes et au
niveau de la transposition de cette
effort en France donc déjà il y a eu un
travail qui a été fait avec les
opérateurs de rénovation au niveau de
l'Allemagne et avec les banques en
Allemagne pour développer justement ces
systèmes d'aide le souci que la ministre
d'ailleurs elle nous avait communiqué
avec nous son souci c'est que en France
on a des opérateurs qui sont beaucoup
plus petits on a beaucoup beaucoup d'ind
distribution d'opérateurs alors que en
Allemagne c'est beaucoup plus centralisé
donc ça a permis à l'Allemagne d'être
plus quelque part mieux organisé au
niveau de justement cette cette ce
développement avec avec les banques mais
ça empêche pas de justement travailler
vers un parcours de financement de la
rénovation donc il faut reconnaître le
point important ici c'est de pas de
reconnaître que les rénovations
énergétiques du bâtiment coûte cher
qu'il faut trouver le financement pour
la rénovation que de faire des aides qui
vont financer que une partie de la
rénovation souvent c'est pas très utile
ça fait peur aux gens parce que le reste
à charge est assez élevé donc de pour le
gouvernement de regarder comment faire
pour avoir un soutien qui couvre
l'ensemble de la rénovation des coûts de
la rénovation
soit à l'aide de subvention mais aussi
soit à l'aide de près organisé avec la
du gouvernement mais peut-être
directement entre les usagers et les
banques donc c'est vraiment au niveau de
cette ingénierie financière que
l'Allemagne a réussi à avancer très bien
à ce niveau là ils ont aussi deux
éléments importants un c'est que leur
rénovation sont toujours accompagnées de
de mettre de rénovation donc des
architectes qui suivent justement les
rénovations du bâtiment dans leur
ensemble et ils font aussi des
vérifications des travaux donc il paient
pour les travaux une fois achevés ils
vont faire des rénovations ils vont
faire des vérifications à la fin donc
tout ça a permis vraiment d'aller plus
loin au niveau allemand sur cette sur ce
point en particulier
au niveau du pays des Pays-Bas les ils
ont fait ils ont développé une approche
en feuille de route à deux niveaux le
premier c'est sur le bâtiment public qui
a aidé justement à développer la filière
parce que quand on a justement un
feuille de route claire au niveau du
bâtiment public ça aide à renforcer les
filières et à donner une perspective
dans le temps ils ont aussi fait des
feuilles de route au niveau régional en
particulier pour déterminer le zonage
pour déterminer où est-ce que on peut
mettre en place développer des réseaux
de chaleur et où est-ce qu'on doit
passer en fait au niveau
de pompe à chaleur dans les bâtiments et
ça ça permet d'engager les acteurs
régionaux et d'avoir une approche qui
est plus coordonnée au niveau de
l'évolution dans le temps
j'ai moins à dire au niveau des des de
la coordination entre les différents
ministères au sur la Suède par contre ce
qui est intéressant en Suède c'est la
Suède c'est le seul pays parmi ceux
qu'on a regardé ou les bâtiments sont
pratiquement entièrement décarbonés donc
ils ont atteint déjà le niveau où on
voudrait nous être et ça ils ont fait ça
par justement ces trois leviers là donc
efficacité énergétique rénovation et
chauffage bas carbone un mélange entre
pompe chaleur et réseau de chaleur ils
ont fait ces développements ils ont
commencé dans les années 70 donc ça a
pris plusieurs décennies commencer avec
des une réglementation sur le neuf assez
strict et ils ont au fil des années
atteint justement maintenant cette cette
ce statut bas carbone
souhaitable
et ça a été du coup le résultat d'une
politique coordonnée sur plusieurs
décennies qui a permis justement
d'atteindre ce niveau et en France on a
une politique plus beaucoup plus jeune
mais elle doit justement se coordonnée
elle doit donner une visibilité
d'ensemble à au secteur pour justement
développer ce sera sur plusieurs
décennies ça va se faire en fait cette
décennie ça doit être vraiment la
décennie qui monte qui remonte le niveau
des rénovations et ensuite ça va prendre
une vingtaine d'années à pouvoir faire
l'ensemble du parc
la création de l'observatoire
juste vous sur l'exemple de la Suède de
la source que ce que vous disiez sur le
sur le fait que bon ils ont des
résultats qui sont qui sont très bons en
tout cas ils ont
mais ils agissent sur deux niveaux là
sur le chauffage et donc réseau de
chaleur et puis pompe à chaleur et puis
sur la rénovation thermique on se pose
souvent la question en France de se dire
parfois faut commencer enfin en tout cas
souvent des critiques pour dire on
commence à changer les chaudières alors
qu'on n'a pas fait on n'a pas fait la
rénovation thermique mais d'un autre
côté on fait la rénovation thermique qui
est pas qui est pas complète donc voilà
donc on se pose toujours cette question
de voilà comme par quoi faut commencer
par quoi faudrait aller
je sais pas si vous êtes du coup vous
avez peut-être plus de précisions sur
comment en fait le processus s'est mis
en place en Suède
non au niveau de la Suède non j'ai pas
plus de précision mais clairement on a
besoin de faire les deux la rénovation
thermique et le chauffage bas carbone
que les deux doivent se développer en
parallèle que dans la stratégie
nationale bacarbonne du gouvernement on
a une trajectoire en parallèle pour les
deux et donc il s'agit pas de faire un
ou l'autre en fait vraiment la stratégie
elle doit inclure les deux mais j'ai pas
de d'information par rapport à la Suède
elle-même
concernant le la création de
l'observatoire donc oui c'était vraiment
une excellente nouvelle d'avoir cette
observatoire là je peux pas vous dire
grand chose par rapport à
aux résultats en fait parce qu'ils ont
soumis un rapport je pense que c'était
en juillet dernier nous on est entre
deux rapports du Haut Conseil pour le
climat on assumait le nôtre en juin et
on prépare celui le prochain donc on n'a
pas encore regardé les données de
l'Observatoire mais on voit bien que sur
sur un défi tel que la rénovation de
l'ensemble du parc du bâtiment cette
observatoire est absolument cruciale que
il doit pouvoir apporter des données de
suivi très fines il doit pouvoir faire
pas les vérifier si par bâtiment bien
sûr mais être capable de dire si dans
l'ensemble le parc du bâtiment
répond aux attentes de devenir de
manière
[Musique]
plus efficace de manière structurée
donc il doit permettre de faire un suivi
en fait de l'ensemble du parc du
bâtiment
donc en ce qui concerne les gestes
individuels donc dans le dans les
rapports du Haut Conseil pour le climat
on a surtout préconisé les gestes la
rénovation globale performante
maintenant il faut que les actions qui
soient qui sont mises en place il faut
qu'elle soit pratique il faut pas non
plus viser
un ensemble de gestes qui soient parfait
mais il faut vraiment pousser les
instruments actuels le plus possible
pour que les dépenses se fassent vers
ces rénovations le plus global possible
plus performant possible le plus
profondes possible et que les obstacles
sont à l'heure actuelle que l'on voit à
l'heure actuelle c'est vraiment le coup
des rénovations c'est vraiment la
disponibilité des travaux de rénovation
et que de développer les instruments
actuels pour en changer les travaux
globaux pourrait permettre justement de
remonter le niveau d'efficacité du parc
maintenant dans quel ordre est-ce qu'on
doit le faire est-ce qu'on doit faire
toutes les rénovations de manière
parfaite tout de suite non on peut faire
aussi des feuilles de route pour la
planification des rénovations globales
donc donc le problème qui existe en fait
le danger le risque c'est que une
personne rénove par exemple les fenêtres
de leurs bâtiments et ensuite ils
s'arrête en se disant bon mais là j'ai
dépensé mes sous et puis j'ai fait mais
j'ai fait ma part et en fait il faut que
les personnes se rendent compte que il y
a tout un travail à faire il y a toute
une route à prendre et que on si on fait
des gestes qui sont individuels et
uniques ces gestes soient mis dans une
trajectoire où on prévoit justement la
rénovation des bâtiments jusqu'à ce
qu'ils atteignent un niveau plus
performant on va pas arriver bien sûr à
une rénovation globale de l'ensemble des
bâtiments qui existent parfaite jusqu'à
2000 d'ici 2050 mais si on peut avec une
combinaison de
instinctifs qui sont qui vont le plus
possible vers cette rénovation globale
avec en parallèle une des carbonations
de la chaleur un chauffage bas carbone
on peut effectivement arriver à une
neutralité carbone dans le secteur du
bâtiment de manière dans les temps quoi
donc ces feuilles de route du cou
deviennent très importantes la
planification du financement pour
effectivement payer les factures ou
donner aux personnes au ménage les
options pour payer les factures de
viennent très importants
donc sur le DPE donc
encore là une fois on est entre deux
rapports donc je peux pas vous trop vous
dire beaucoup trop vous dire d'éléments
par rapport à sa performance jusqu'à
présent la difficulté que l'on a que
l'on a soulevé avec le DPE actuel c'est
que on voit mal comment le relier avec
les objectifs qui sont dans la stratégie
nationale bac carbone donc cette
stratégie elle est maintenant en cours
de révision donc ça sera du coup avec
une combinaison du DPE actuelle
j'imagine et de la stratégie nationale
bas carbone de pouvoir dire quels
objectifs on doit atteindre avec quel
nombre de bâtiments
dans les propositions de la de la
convention citoyenne pour le climat là
j'ai pas ou non plus beaucoup d'éléments
à vous apporter je vais juste noter que
dans le secteur du bâtiment comme dans
bien d'autres secteurs ont sous-estime
en fait les
mesures de sobriété et ça m'amène aussi
à votre dernière question donc
est-ce qu'on peut avec des mesures de
sobriété réduire le l'utilisation
d'énergie dans le bâtiment oui bien sûr
il y a des mesures de sobriété dans le
parc actuel donc beaucoup en termes
d'efficacité de réduction de
l'utilisation de chauffage par exemple
dans les pièces qui sont pas utilisées
par exemple de en particulier ou sur les
plages horaires où on a moins besoin de
chauffage et tout ça ça peut se faire de
manière structurelle le il s'agit pas de
simplement de dire aux gens de baisser
la température mais il s'agit d'avoir
des des guides directeurs d'avoir du
zonage dans les buildings etc
par contre on peut pas on peut pas miser
complètement sur les mesures de
sobriétés bien sûr que non parce que à
la fin on aura quand même un besoin de
chauffage et que c'est les bâtiments
perdent leur énergie on aura un problème
tout simplement de énergétique globale
donc c'est rénovations énergétique elles
sont essentielles c'est c'est une des
actions en réponse au réchauffement
climatique qui coûte le plus cher et
c'est pour ça que la planification de
ces actions et leur financement dans le
temps et sont si important
merci madame la Présidente alors je
laisse la parole à Martha Sidrac merci
madame la Présidente merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces explications madame Le Quéré
je moi je souhaitais en fait revenir sur
un certain nombre de vos propos quand on
réfléchit au bâtiment autant on a des je
dirais des normes des indicateurs
lorsqu'il s'agit de concevoir un
bâtiment neuf aujourd'hui avec la loi
Haget qu'on a même des diagnostics pour
faire lorsque le bâtiment arrive en fin
de vie et devient un déchet donc on peut
diagnostiquer les matériaux qui le
composent pour pouvoir le réutiliser là
on s'intéresse en réalité à sa vie donc
entre le moment où il est né et le
moment où il décède si je peux me les
exprimer comme ça donc j'ai presque
envie de dire est-ce que et j'ai cru
comprendre qu'à travers vos différents
propos finalement vous effectivement
c'est un sujet qui sur lequel vous vous
interrogez la pathologie en fait c'est à
dire quelle est la pathologie du
bâtiment c'est à dire
résolution pour quelle éventuelle
diagnostic alors du coup très naïvement
je me posais la question de la même
manière que nous avons allé voir le
médecin de temps en temps pour voir si
tout va bien et quel soin adapter plutôt
que d'attendre d'être très très malade
et à ce moment-là le process devient
très lourd nous devrions nous pas avoir
une réflexion de ce type là aujourd'hui
dans nos politiques publiques et
pourquoi pas imaginer une espèce de
check-up adaptée donc un diagnostic
périodique sur notre patrimoine
immobilier qui permettrait de dire voilà
dans ce cas de figure
le l'intervention pour être plus légère
et donc on met en place ce qu'il faut en
face pour pouvoir y remédier dans telle
autre cas de figure parce que ben on a
des patrimoines datant d'époque
différentes avec des des méthodes de
construction différentes et or cette
approche là on le voit à travers les
parents gonages ici et là ça émerge en
revanche en France on n'a pas encore
cette approche là d'autant plus que
lorsque vous parliez des petits gestes
de nos concitoyens lorsqu'ils ont envie
d'aller vers une rénovation parfois ils
sont un peu démunis parce que ils ne
sont pas spécialistes ils ne sont pas
experts ils savent pas ce qui est le
mieux je prends pour exemple typiquement
la ventilation on sait que si on veut
avoir un effet un chauffage efficace il
faut aussi qu'on s'interroge sur la
qualité de la ventilation nos logements
par exemple mais il y a plein de choses
de ce type là donc quid d'un check-up
adapté périodique adapté à nos bâtiments
je voulais avoir votre sentiment là
dessus merci
merci aussi votre question éclaire par
contre on n'a pas trop réfléchi sur la
question donc
bon je peux juste vous donner mon
appréciation personnelle par rapport à
ce que je connais du bâtiment oui
pourquoi pas oui effectivement un des
problèmes que l'on a c'est que on
connaît mal le bâtiment et c'est pour ça
que l'Observatoire énergétique du
bâtiment est si importante pour pouvoir
apprendre des expériences déjà connues
vécues et pouvoir
échanger sur ces expériences
le
par rapport à
les réflexions sur les diagnostics donc
les éléments
informationsnels par rapport aux
rénovation énergétique du bâtiment sont
très très importantes justement pour
guider les ménages au travers ces
rénovations c'est un sujet technique
c'est un sujet vraiment complexe qui
implique non seulement la connaissance
du bâtiment mais aussi le financement
qui va derrière donc c'est important
d'avoir justement des maîtres d'ouvrage
des feuilles de route au niveau du
bâtiment pour pouvoir aider les ménages
dans cette démarche il y a aussi les
besoins de formation dont j'ai parlé ou
tout début donc formation au niveau de
la filière elle-même une formation sur
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire de faire une
rénovation énergétique performante
comment est-ce qu'on fait au niveau de
la ventilation pointe point très
important que vous avez apporté comment
est-ce qu'on fait au niveau du confort
d'été et aussi les éléments de chauffage
bac carbone qui qui vont dans cette
dans ce dans qui entre dans ce besoin de
connaissances et de formation de la
filière donc on a besoin que le
gouvernement appuie la filière vers
cette formation
des maîtres d'ouvrage dans le secteur du
bâtiment
il y avait Franck Montaugé
merci madame la Présidente merci Madame
Guéret pour votre présentation vous
explications vous avez évoqué dans votre
propos la nécessité de de des
programmations plus réelles de
financement public pour la rénovation
énergétique la question se pose me
semble-t-il aussi pour les
investissements privés et les organismes
financiers prêteurs est-ce que le Haut
Conseil pour le climat travaille-t-il
fait-il des préconisations ou des
recommandations sur la dimension
économique et financière du problème de
la rénovation énergétique je pense en
particulier au prix du carbone au niveau
du prix du carbone ça valorisation et
également au taux d'actualisation qui
sont utilisés dans les modèles de
décision économiques et financiers
donc font partie les prêts ou les
emprunts qui concourent aux travaux de
au financement des travaux de rénovation
énergétique voilà petite parenthèse sans
faire le sachant les taux
d'actualisation permettent de donner
plus ou moins de poids au futur ou au
présent dans les décisions à prendre
aujourd'hui comme celle d'investir pour
des de la rénovation énergétique dont le
temps de retour finalement sur
investissement va s'apprécier sur 20 30
40 50 ans ou plus voilà donc c'est ces
deux points là ils sont assez
fondamentaux justement en se passant du
point de vue des investisseurs
susceptibles donc de s'engager dans des
opérations lourdes et sur la durée de
financement de la rénovation énergétique
merci pour votre réponse madame
merci pour la question effectivement
donc il y a une programmation des
financements publics à prévoir mais il y
a aussi les financements privés à
prévoir en parallèle donc c'est pour ça
que ces instruments sont aussi
importants et le plein la planification
du financement et c'est important donc
on n'a pas regardé au conseil pour le
climat en détail les hypothèses qui vont
derrière justement ces ces dimensions
financières par contre on voit bien que
le prix du carbone donc le gel de la
taxe carbone en particulier a vraiment
eu une importance par rapport aux
esthétifs économiques qui étaient
sous-jacent à la mise en place de la
trajectoire de la stratégie nationale à
carbone c'est-à-dire que quand le
gouvernement a fait s'attraper sa
stratégie ils avaient une augmentation
de du prix du carbone qui en fait n'a
pas eu lieu et donc sauf pour la
dernière année avec la crise énergétique
et donc ça probablement joué contre
cette trajectoire là actuelle ce qui ce
qui va sûrement se passer là ou en tout
cas ce qui est en train de se passer
c'est que au niveau européen donc on a
ce nouvel objectif européen et une
partie du secteur du bâtiment va passer
probablement sur le développement d'un
deuxième c'est que donc le le
j'ai oublié le l'acronyme qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire le
oui merci merci le système d'échange de
quota donc à l'heure actuelle il y a un
système d'échange de quota qui touche
l'industrie et l'énergie et il y en a un
deuxième qui est en cours de discussion
qui couvrirait une partie du secteur du
bâtiment et du transport et donc ceux
ce mécanisme va effectivement remplacer
le rôle que le prix du carbone de que la
taxe carbone avait en France et donc et
donc il va venir appuyer si on pense
simplement au niveau de des émissions il
va venir appuyer les
les actions dans ce domaine en France
par contre un sécu ça prend plusieurs
années à se mettre en place et donc ça
va pas aider du coup dans l'immédiat ou
en tout cas très peu et ça dispense pas
de travailler sur les autres instruments
qui effectivement mettent un prix du
carbone mais après du carbone indirect
du coup quand on parle de réglementation
en particulier
oui merci madame la Présidente vous avez
pas répondu en partie à ma question que
vous voulez poser en répondant à ma
voisine sur la parce que je pense que
l'action d'information est extrêmement
importante les artisans sont souvent des
prescripteurs pour les propriétaires et
par contre moi ce que je ce que je
rencontre sont souvent
un peu critiques par rapport à la
certification RGE donc qu'est-ce qu'il
faudrait faire évoluer cette cette
certification ou comment engager la
profession
dans une réelle mission de conseils pour
les propriétaires
[Musique]
merci madame la présidente madame le CAC
j'aimerais en fait évoquer le sujet pour
ma part essentiel de la gouvernance je
ne sais pas si vous avez pu travailler
ou en tout cas nous faire des
préconisations sur le sujet vous avez
mentionné la nécessité d'une meilleure
coordination des acteurs des dispositifs
dans le cadre de ces politiques
publiques et on le voit aujourd'hui à la
complexité dans la conduite de ces
politiques explique certaines des
difficultés que vous avez mentionnées
également tout à l'heure notamment
l'accompagnement insuffisant des ménages
le manque d'évaluation de certains
dispositifs et puis de cette politique
dans sa globalité est-ce que donc je le
disais vous avez aujourd'hui il y a des
préconisations quel est selon vous le
meilleur échelon pour conduire
efficacement cette politique tout le
monde s'accorde pour dire que les
territoires sont aujourd'hui agiles
résilients dans la conduite des
changements notamment pour accompagner
les changements climatiques mais faut-il
une gouvernance territoriale plus
renforcée je vous remercie
merci le sujet de la répartition de
l'effort entre le National et le
territorial et voir le local c'est un
point très très important
du coup
le niveau national est absolument
essentiel pour
mettre en place déterminer les
trajectoires et les objectifs et par
contre
cette cette trajectoire nationale elle
doit en fait être suivie de objectif
régionaux qui sont mises en place avec
quelques années habituellement quelques
années de retard il y a des leviers au
niveau national en particulier toutes
les aides dont on venait parler dont on
vient de parler mais il y a aussi des
leviers au niveau territorial et
régional qui sont mises en oeuvre de
manière très très disparate dans les
différentes régions donc il y a des
régions qui sont mieux organisées plus
en avance qui ont effectivement des de
en tout cas de suivi des émissions et il
y en a d'autres pas du tout donc il y a
un travail à faire là je peux pas vous
dire je peux pas répondre directement à
votre question sur quel est le la
meilleure répartition en fait entre le
niveau national et le niveau territorial
mais simplement pour dire que il y a des
financements au niveau territorial qui
pourrait être mieux mobilisés pour aller
accompagner les acteurs régionaux locaux
pour aller plus vite au niveau régional
et que on manque de coordination
nationale territoriale par rapport à ça
dans le cadre de la loi
climat résilience le Haut Conseil doit
faire un rapport justement sur la
gouvernance nationale régionale du coup
en 2024 donc on va se pendre je suis sur
ce sujet mais pas à l'heure actuelle
merci madame la Présidente y a-t-il
d'autres questions de la part de nos
collègues monsieur le rapporteur
un petit un petit complément sur la
savoir si vous avez travaillé sur la
question des matériaux biosourcés
que ça soit le bois évidemment mais
change pas etc et notamment sur le biais
du carbone parce que c'est vrai qu'on
sait que à la fois c'est un moyen de
stocker du carbone et de stocker
durablement du coup dans le bâtiment et
je sais que sur l'ensemble de la de la
filière se pose la question en fait de
la de la valeur de ce carbone et de
comment on peut à la fois on peut le
donner une on peut lui donner une valeur
et faire en sorte que justement ça ça
contribue à au développement de la
filière si vous aviez travaillé sur
cette question merci un tout petit peu
dans le sens où dans la stratégie
justement du gouvernement il y a une
approche de l'utilisation du bois comme
matériaux de construction pour justement
diminuer les émissions dans l'ensemble
par contre ce qu'on voit au niveau des
forêts alors actuelle c'est plutôt un
dépérissement des forêts en partie à
cause du réchauffement climatique mais
surtout à cause de du manque de
plantation en fait de la gestion des
forêts qui doit être plus active
et donc en théorie on peut en fait
arriver à une stratégie qui utilise des
matériaux de bois de construction et qui
stockent plus de carbone dans les forêts
mais alors actuellement on est plutôt
dans un dans un dispositif qui est
équilibre il y a des discussions par
exemple dans le cadre des Assises de la
forêt de l'année dernière qui vise
justement à renforcer le la gestion de
la forêt mais il faut vraiment que ce
travail se fasse en parallèle sinon on
fait des prélèvements qui sont pas
remplacés par du bois par des pouces
neuves donc effectivement oui c'est
c'est une solution positive mais qui
doit être gérée dans l'ensemble aussi
dans un contexte de gestion de la forêt
merci beaucoup madame la Présidente on
vous souhaite une bonne fin de journée
et merci pour cette audition très
intéressante